pues sabemos que Corea del Norte ha
lanzado un misil balístico de Rango
intermedio lo ha lanzado en dirección al
este lo ha hecho desde la provincia de
chagang en el norte del país y sabemos
que este misil ha recorrido unos 4.500
4.600 kilómetros alcanzando una altura
máxima de casi mil kilómetros esto
supone dos cosas uno como bien
comentabas se trata el proyectil en
norcoreano que más distancia ha
recorrido nunca porque Corea del Norte
anteriormente ha disparado misiles que
potencialmente tienen más rango pero lo
ha hecho con un ángulo muy abierto de
manera que
la parábola que dibujan hace que el
misil recorra en realidad en menos
distancia lo segundo que implica es que
antes de caer al océano Pacífico el
misil ha sobrevolado la prefectura de
amor y en el norte de Japón y eso ha
supuesto que las autoridades activen
alertas de misiles pidiendo a la
población que se resguarde de acuerdo a
las características de este misil parece
que parece que se María de un Juan son
12 que es un misil que ya hemos visto
antes y que él precisamente Corea del
Norte disparó dos veces sobre sobre
Japón ya en 2017 como he